.
- Montréal, la multicolore.
La métropole s'est réveillée
avec des élus de chacun desc. Ce
bleu azur sur presque toute
la province, l'îre
les partis d'opposition :
libéraux surtout dans l'ouest,
solidaires au centre,
dans l'est.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Je pense que les Montréalais
ils souhaitent que tous les
partis portent la voix
des Montréalais à l'Assemblée
nationale.
- Il y a deux Québec, le Qué
du centre de Montréal...
et Montréal.
- Il y a plus d'opinions,
il y a plus d'échanges avec plus
de communautés.
- L'opposition y voit un motif
d'inquiétude.
AREF SALEM, chef de l'opposition
officielle, Ville de Montréal
qui viennent de Montréal. Donc,
mon inqule vient de
ce fait : que le nombre n'est
pas présent, on n'est pas assez
- Le premier ministre a tenu
rer.rer.rer.rer.rer.rer.
- C'est trop important Montréal,
notre métropole, entre autres
et on va continuer de travailler
avec la mairesse puis de trouver
des façons de... se rapprocher
- En plus de Chantal Rouleau,
réélue facilement dans Pointe-
aux-Trembles, l'ancienneère de ,
oivin-Roy, a gagné dans
Anjou-Louis-Riel, qui votaitdepe
Pour porter la voix de Montréal,
il y a aussi un atout
supplémentaire, au
de ces élections.
Pour porter la voix de Montr
il y a aussi un atout
de ces élections.
RUDEL, ancien ministre
des Affaires municipales
partis qui sont des députéséal.,
un député ne peut pas appeler
Un chef de parti peut.- Et, de e
Montréalais voient la Ville
comme un
- Je pense qu'ils sont capables,
les maires et de
grandes villes, de pouvoir
s'imposer.
'à peu p'à peu p'à peu p'à peu e
source de financement, c'est
les taxeres. On peut pas
arriver avec ça, ça se peut
juste pas.
- C'est d'ailleurs l'un desles .
L'autre gros morceau, pacte ver:
10 milliards sur 5 ans réclamés
pour la transition écologique.
Ici Mat